welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins I've been sitting
in for David Pakman today if you want
more from me you can find me on youtube
at youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire
you can also follow me on Twitter at
Ferren farr Oh in balanced um I want to
talk about something recently that Eric
Holder said and no I'm not talking about
him saying he's not gonna run for
president recently Eric Holder said
something that really bothered me he
said that the next Democratic president
should consider adding two more seats to
the US Supreme Court you know so that
progressives or liberals could then have
the majority on there again
right pretty simple next Democratic
president comes along he or she adds
however many seats they need packs him
with some liberals in there and then
BOOM all the problems with the judiciary
are suddenly fixed except they're not
adding more seats to the US Supreme
Court is going to do absolutely nothing
to fix the massive problem that
Republicans have created in the judicial
branch of our government and it's so
disappointing
and honestly downright disgusting to me
to see somebody like Eric Holder who
served as Attorney General has worked at
corporate law firms for his private
practice career to be so naive and
clueless about the real problem of our
court system here in the United States
do you want to know what the real
problem is the problem as mayor Pete
boot eggheads recently pointed out is
that Democrats don't understand the
importance of court packing and I know
when you say court packing it sounds
like it's a bad thing but Republicans
have been doing it for decades and they
don't just care about the Supreme Court
like Democrats do and I'm sorry hate me
if you want for saying that but
Democrats only care about the Supreme
Court when was the last time you heard a
Democrat other than buta jej come out
and say we got to do something about
these lower courts that's what I'm
running on we're gonna support judges at
every level
or do you hear talking points if well
there could be two Supreme Court's
openings and we don't want Republicans
to get ahold of those Donald Trump took
office with well over 100 lower court
vacancies and the one thing one thing
this man has done well in his presidency
is appoint those judges one out of every
six judges right now sitting on a US
District Court is a Donald Trump
appointee one-sixth of the district
courts here in the United States
Trump appointees it gets worse if it
could get worse it gets worse the most
recent addition is a woman by the name
of Alison Jones rushing Alison Jones
rushing about a week ago was confirmed
by the Senate Alison Jones rushing is 36
years old Alison Jones rushing at 36
years old just received a lifetime
appointment to the federal judiciary a
lifetime appointment to the federal
judiciary on the district court at the
age of 36 had only been practicing law
for nine years
she's only tried four cases to verdict
or judgment for cases in her life and in
good health she could serve 50 years on
that District Court she is a trump
appointee she is a Republican minded she
is a pro corporate person anti consumers
50 years maybe 40 on a bad year it's not
the only one we've got other right-wing
anti-consumer judges that have been
appointed age 39 so you're probably
looking at 40 years from that one age 46
probably 30 to 35 years because that's
the difference that's why this matter
that's why these lower courts matter and
I'll get some more numbers in a minute
they're going to shock you but
Republicans are putting younger and
younger people on our courts and giving
them lifetime appointment
reshaping the lower courts for a
generation and a half I mean we are
talking 40 to 50 years some of these
people are going to serve while
Democrats whine and cry about the
Supreme Court and I understand the
Supreme Court's important you'd have to
be an idiot not to know it but it's not
the most important it's not and you're a
hundred percent wrong if you think that
and that's why I disagree with what Eric
Holder had to say because here's the
numbers circuit courts are often the
last word in federal court cases the
Supreme Court hears only about 100 to
150 Appeals of the more than 7,000 cases
that come before the nation's 13 circuit
courts each year so you've got your
Supreme Court we're gonna hear about a
hundred to 150 cases and then you have
the district courts one in six or Trump
appointees 7,000 cases decided and done
at that level so you tell me which one's
more important the Republican pact area
that here's 7,000 cases and decides them
for good or the group that hears about a
hundred 150 that you know has one more
republican than democrat that's a
no-brainer that should be a no-brainer
to everyone watching this the lower
courts matter and put together as a
whole the lower courts do matter more
than the Supreme Court and I know it's
easier to overturn a lower court than it
is a Supreme Court but it's not
impossible to overturn a Supreme Court
case if it were difficult to do we
wouldn't all be worried about roe v wade
getting overturned the balance of power
in that top court shifts it always has
it always will just like with the lower
courts but what Republicans are doing
today is making sure that that lower
court balance of power doesn't shift for
another 50 years
that's longevity that's thinking ahead
and I hate to say it again but that is
something that the Democrats
fundamentally have never understood and
if they did understand it they never
took it seriously